the omnibus bill that Republicans gave
President Trump yesterday is a total
betrayal of him and those who elected
him it was as though they left him
without arms to swim in a sea of sharks
risking our health and safety now I told
you a long time ago that the
establishment was anti-trump remember
how panicked they were when it looked
like he would actually win the
nomination the party elders petrified
because he was beholding to no one and
in spite of their back slapping and glad
handling they just proved that they
still are once he was elected the
establishments mission was to make sure
that he did not succeed candidate Donald
Trump ran on a promise to build a border
wall and in 2017 January Speaker Paul
Ryan and Senate Majority Leader Mitch
McConnell promised to build that wall
with 15 billion dollars the bill they
presented had only one point six billion
short more than 13 billion and they
specifically precluded the use of that
money for the wall prototypes the
president looked at in California this
betrayal should be no surprise Ryan and
McConnell never cared about his
succeeding two months after he was
elected Ryan failed to deliver votes on
the health care bill the one that he had
seven years to work on the one that Ryan
hid under lock and key in the basement
of Congress the one they pulled because
of the embarrassment of not having
enough votes to pass it when they had
the House the Senate and the Oval so why
did the president sign this bill we
looked at in the veto I looked very
seriously at the veto I was thinking
about doing a veto but because of the
incredible gains that we've been able to
make for the military that overrode any
thank you the first order of government
is the protection of its citizens this
bill included 700 billion to shore up
the military so destroyed devalued and
diminished by Barack Obama as Obama took
the army down to World War two levels
North Korea was launching ICBMs with
nuclear war tips threatening Guam Hawaii
and all Americans meanwhile Iran
spinning centrifuges allegedly for
nuclear medicine while at the same time
threatening the extermination of both
Israel and America and Russia now in
possession of 20 percent of our uranium
thanks to Bubba and his wife continuing
to build their nuclear arsenal
so faced with this triad the president
chose to put our defense in the
strongest position to protect us and to
protect our servicemembers our arsenal
will now include the stealth f-35
bombers that literally are invisible to
the enemy you know any leaders success
is based upon the ability to take action
and get results
it's what Trump does it's what he did
with deregulation it's what he did by
removing the individual mandate in the
tax reform bill it's what he just did
with bump stocks these guys funded the
sanctuary cities the ones that protect
illegal criminals risking the life and
safety of American citizens like Kate
Steinle sanctuary cities where federal
and local law enforcement are pitted
against each other and they funded
Planned Parenthood that performs more
than 300,000 abortions a year at a cost
of five hundred million dollars a year
Congress prefers rogue cities where
illegal criminals are protected and
Americans at risk
Congress prefers no border wall so
illegals can cross bringing poisonous
drugs that take the lives of over 1,000
Americans a week that's what I said
1,000 Americans a week and while we pay
for border walls for those in Tunisia
and Libya Americans will suffer a plague
of drug overdoses from
illegal drugs that come into this
country from Mexico 90% of the heroin
use in this country comes through the
southern border and although we are only
5% of the world's population we use 80%
of its opioids with a potency 50 times
that of heroin and 100 times that of
morphine the one the establishment is
not willing to build a wall to stop the
one that America that the Congress is
killing more than a thousand of us a
week by not building the wall opioids
and illegal drugs coming from Mexico
folks these are double-talking two-faced
politicians who care only about
themselves lobbyists their contributions
and the next election so here we are
Democrats crowing that they funded
sanctuary cities Planned Parenthood and
only one point six billion for a
see-through wall while they kept out
daca which the president was willing to
give them so the Democrats can use it
against him in the upcoming election
folks I want to be real clear this is
not on President Trump this is on the
leadership for the Republican Party the
very people this president should be
able to count on in truth the president
is surrounded by inept incompetent
warriors and this bill is a reflection
of just that total betrayal by the
Senate and House leadership how dare
these Republicans play politics with our
lives and the lives of our children with
all this namby-pamby nonsense about
their security border the president and
the people who voted for him have been
betrayed by Speaker Paul Ryan and Leader
Mitch McConnell and the people in
Kentucky and Wisconsin need to make sure
that these guys are defeated in the next
election so this president can carry on
the agenda that we elected him to do and
that's my open